hey guys at seven if you're afraid of
doing something if you're afraid of
trying something new but it's something
that you know can help somebody or help
a lot of people out then you owe it to
yourself but you also owe it to the
people who you can help to share your
gift and change their lives and that's
going to mean stepping into the fear
it's going to mean stepping outside your
comfort zone it's gonna mean doing
something that is scary for you but it's
so worth it I promise you and it's not
as scary as you thought it would be as
you get into it and I want to share a
quick example I almost didn't do these
YouTube videos I've got hundreds of its
reached tons of people and I almost
didn't do these videos for two reasons
1i have some kind of mild form of
Tourette's I've never gone and actually
got a diagnosed but my whole life I've
had some kind of tick with my body and
it's gotten at your little better over
the years but I still have some facial
tics so I remember when I was younger I
would blink a lot I had to I had the
blink a lot and I couldn't walk on
cracks in the sidewalk of those a crack
I'd have to step over it and I used to
walk and and kick my heel up to touch my
butt all sorts of strange things you
know no rhyme or reason to it and I
became very self-conscious about it and
now when I'm thinking you'll notice that
my ears move so I might if I I don't you
guys can see that maybe not can you see
that a little bit so my head is moving a
little bit my ears move our i may do
this with my eye sometimes and and I was
afraid that this is gonna be on video
everybody's going to see this you know
millions of people will watch this and
you know if I'm supposed to be
this expert I didn't want to I didn't
want to see this in myself on videos
scared is afraid I was nervous and every
time you know I'm thinking those things
come out the other thing that held me
back from starting the videos was I tend
to like to think about what I'm going to
say before I say it and it doesn't lead
for very good debate it doesn't leave
for very passionate arguments I remember
in my relationships you know the purser
wis would be upset that I couldn't fight
with them I couldn't respond because
because I couldn't think fast enough
you're not the process things i'm a slow
thinker i have to think about what I'm
gonna say think of what what what's
coming at me and digested and I don't
always come up with a quick answer and
that's not great for video either write
the people want to watch people who are
going off and are really opinionated and
you know if you look at the the
celebrities in the world in this field
if you look at like Howard Stern those
guys they're there they're shock jocks
right they they have strong opinions
they they are you know good debaters and
and that's not me and and so I worried
that those two things at the unified the
facial tics and and the lack of a strong
opinion or me wanting to think about
what i wanted to say even now right I'm
thinking about what I want to say before
I say it and it deletes the passion I
gets was that with the message I felt
like those things would hold me back
from doing video and hold me back from
be able to reach people and and made me
scared and nervous and so I never
started doing video it took me a long
time to work up the courage to get in
front of a camera and press record and
the first videos haha man i spent like a
week working on my first video I don't
know it just took me forever I never
liked what I saw and even now I'm still
really critical of it but it's totally
worth it
and really the best part of my day is
when I see the comments coming back from
you guys with how my thoughts have
helped your business and saved you and
kept you going and you guys keep me
going it really is the best part of my
day watching the comments on the videos
come in and I would have missed out on
that you know I would have missed out on
on one of the happiest parts of my day
every day and and missed out on the
ability to help a lot of people if I was
too afraid to to do this to step into
the fear and record my first video I
promise you it gets a lot easier you
know I've done hundreds of these now and
each one I don't have to prepare as much
for I don't get as nervous for is a lot
easier to to put out and I can't imagine
all the I guess the lack of joy that I
would have if I didn't do this if this
wasn't a part of my life like this is
part of my life is part of my regular
week it's part of what I do all the time
and it brings me so much joy and so it
encourage you whatever project you're
thinking about whatever whatever new
idea you have for your business or in
your life that's going to stretch you
you know you really want to do this and
you get all excited and you go to sleep
and the next day you wake up and and you
lost the confidence to do it that was me
for weeks whatever that is just do it
you know summon in whatever that
strength you have inside you and just
try it try it on a small scale and and
if it's something as easy as a video
just do it for yourself to start you
know it doesn't mean you have to publish
it just try it whatever whatever fear
you have step into it and the more you
do it the less you're going to be afraid
and the less you're going to live with
the regret down the road thinking and
wishing that I really wish that I had
done that I really wish I had tried that
and I don't want you to live with that
regret for the rest of your life and I
want you to have a joyful happy life
that impacts a lot of people so so for
today don't be afraid go for it and see
what happens if you guys like this video
thumbs up below you just found out these
videos make my day so please leave a
comment underneath I love seeing those
comments come in thank you guys so much
i'll see you soon